turning to missouri in the latest on a
deadly train crash there dramatic video
taken from inside the train shows
stunned passengers after seven of the
amtrak trains cars flipped onto their
sides at least three people were killed
and more than 40 hurt with more on what
caused the crash taylor johnson with our
kansas city affiliate kc-tv is near the
scene taylor good morning
good morning officials believe that that
crash happened at an uncontrolled
railroad crossing which means that the
only warning that drivers had were a
stop sign and a railroad crossing sign
so that means there were no lights or
crossing rails that's typical for rural
areas like this one but the ntsb will
look to determine just how long the
engineer had to react
damn it
it happened
a barefoot passenger stepped on glass
windows while attempting to gain their
footing inside one of the cars of the
amtrak train that had been tossed on its
side train derailment multiple injuries
one female under the train at this time
the crash occurred at 12 42 in the
afternoon
we hit a truck
someone was crossing eight cars and two
locomotives of amtrak's southwest chief
train 4 were carrying at least 207
passengers and 12 crew members from los
angeles to chicago
we were in rural missouri
ron goulet was a passenger heading to
chicago for a connecting departure i
felt
an impact the car was turning on its
side
and people were flying in direct all
directions officials say the train
collided with a dump truck that was
stopped at a crossing killing one person
in the truck and at least two train
passengers
cell phone video from the interior shows
passengers scrambling for their
belongings after the crash when i turned
back later it had been completely
crushed
it was kind of terrifying realizing just
how close i was to
not being here right now at least 40
other passengers were injured several
airlifted to area hospitals former ntsb
chair and cbs news analyst robert
sumwall amtrak does now have outward
facing video cameras as well as inward
facing video cameras they will be able
to see the
uh the
truck and see at what point it enters
the the tracks
amtrak says it fully supports the ntsb's
investigation and they say that they're
going to send a 16 person team out here
to investigate the scene of the crash
but this is the second amtrak crash to
happen within the last two days one hit
a car with five people inside three were
killed and two were taken to the
hospital gail
thank you taylor johnson